because i'm gonna get wasted i just
finished a cold cup of 42 and i'm about
to go for my second one courtney what
the [ __ ] are you on
i don't know what's going on so i'm just
appreciating my bread
kylie jenner is back with yet another
jingle
and everyone including celebs are
obsessed
singing career maybe i don't know move
over
rise and shine kylie's latest tune
wasted has sophie turner joe jonas
and bella hadid vibing cause i'm gonna
get wasted
i just finished a cold cup of 42 and i'm
about to go for my second one courtney
what the [ __ ] are you on
i don't know what's going on so i'm just
appreciating my bread
in the now viral scene from the latest
episode of keeping up
the kardashian jenner fam is in palm
springs
and tensions are high between kylie and
kendall who just
argued over an outfit before dinner
oh like you deserve the outfit more it
was
for me whatever you're hater you're not
going to ruin my night i'm having a good
time
tonight fast forward to the restaurant
kylie asked the server for
another drink and that's when she breaks
out
into a song cause i'm gonna get wasted
i just finished a whole cup of 42 and
i'm about to go for my second one
courtney what
are you on i don't know what's going on
so i'm just
appreciating my bread and the moment has
become
another viral meme for kylie she even
played into the hype
by recreating it herself cause i'm gonna
get wasted i just finished a whole cup
of 42 and i'm about to go for my second
one courtney what the [ __ ] are you on
the makeup mogul gave bella joe and
sophie's impersonations
the thumbs up by reposting both videos
to her instagram story she also
commented under bella's post
writing quote iconic my diamond earring
came up in the ocean and it's gone
there's people that are dying viral
moments are nothing new for kylie's
famous fam
and impersonating those moments is
nothing new for joe jonas
earlier this year he teamed up with his
brothers
to recreate the iconic don't be rude
kardashian fight scene don't be
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
don't be [ __ ] throw the thing on me
i'll hurt you don't do that
oh my god kim kardashian fangirled over
the joe bros acting skills
by reposting the video writing quote omg
i love you guys and while so many of the
show's most
famous moments come out of fights kim's
made it clear to e.t in the past
there is nothing but love between she
and her sisters
i just think like we're definitely a
close family like
more than probably normal but having a
show where we have to work together we
have to
be together i mean i think it just
brings us
[Music]
closer